and I every time I see this the buttons
too light for them because we can see
what they pick and always it messes me
up because super noon uses touchpad for
sparking what is wrong with you guys
what it's great it's the entire
controller 50% of your controller is the
sparking button
it's like the entire face just your
thumb that is fast though working I
can't imagine
I told super noon that if he really
wants to be a kid boot player he's got a
head but his controller to activates
well I hope he does someday that would
be like he just does like the horu and
he just hits it with his head that would
be socially that seems to be appropriate
that's like the best way to activate it
I think yeah man the way to go pull
under that you got to become one with
your candy pad sparking now this game
could go back and forth easily both of
these are really strong players oh yeah
it's great to see super noon up there
you know he's been on the grind working
hard really training hard for this and
he needs the point yeah needs the points
[Music]
right now hard you got to be wanting
like top three is what I was asking
ringing so I got a win dude I was like
what are the point situations like for
you he's like I'm gonna win for the gold
I don't blame them I mean this is our
Twitter's finals here in Puerto Rico oh
the small bun check for once no you
don't need fun well she loves a bunch
now doesn't need them as we see him drop
a combo immediately I think I like that
choice yeah runs up stack is the 2l this
come out super hard to challenge there
there's not that many good options oh it
looked like he tried to reflect then you
got a key blast yeah
Oh for those overhead yeah super noon Oh
almost got blown up for the disks there
because he ended up hitting the assist
character yeah he took some damage but
at least he got out of the corner pin
block balls in a Bartok I like the
patient so far from super noon Christie
trying to get a little bit of zoning in
here something that's free that does
actually arrives with and he's gonna get
a super - in taking noon back to the
corner here going into the level 3a
double overhead good block so far he's
been on defense a lot of this set
finally gets opened up yeah that heavies
gonna do it to them for the extension no
meter necessary Christian without a
scratch on them and kid buu in Bartow
we're pretty beat up right Bartok down
now I could do a lot of life well we try
to reflect on the board here going into
that level three right off the bat
pink matter and now is she gonna be put
on defensive with an assist available
for super noon here staggers I like to I
like the use of it tries to go back in
use the foot
yeah back is great teleport he's gonna
get the combo afterwards I swear from
Chris bought a meter available to level
one go into the vacuum of space
pretty close yeah little tiny bit health
left a lot of blue light if he can find
that time to snap he's going to good
super - in and that is gonna be the end
of Kid Buu super noon already down to
his GT Goku and sparking you know III
feeling he probably wasn't gonna try the
tag because he was probably gonna get
sniped out for it so he just kind of
like ran in and was like I might as well
try to make this work it's scary when
you're at that point in especially
because Kris she's doing a great job at
rotating his assistant yeah flash to get
these super he's gonna be a big drop in
the corner it's tough to read a lot of
time with the regular version so each
version was a good call yeah look for
the reflec powerful win is ya ready
that's fair ball you called it hey does
this a lot it's really common for Chris
and it's it's not easy to punish because
you just don't know when he's gonna end
it but nobody in their life has ever lab
the punish so that our back state in the
front the whole time plus frames they
get the head
QH uses of the smash extend it sliding
knock down not gonna spend the bar just
yet finally he was trying to beat it out
that's parking almost there but Chris
she's sparking with that combo their
counter sparks he's gonna build a ton of
meter on this but I don't imagine him to
be able to kill he's grinding on the
light bar off the drop is unfortunate
sparking is already out but gets that
whooping fist there yeah this is the
kill even with sparking - Regan regained
the live didn't even need another super
air ball yeah so gave one very clean for
Christiaan viously he hardly took a
scratch for most of the game and he just
did a really good job of weathering the
storm super noon you can see like he
wants to swarm you he wants to smother
you and you know Chris is a really
defensive player overall so he's trying
to not engage like that kind of get out
of there both happy birthday here both
of them early
probably a snap I got to imagine oh yeah
there is still enough of the chunk there
but it's coming back pretty quickly
right he did 50% the freeze up very
quickly mixup and sparse available
that's a kill early and even though you
don't get the blue live in the back
there who cares because Frieza just got
smoked immediately
you're out of here yeah very well done I
mean that's what super noon one of the
last game right like he just wanted to
smother and get in before Chris cheek
and establish space and slow things down
and that was a clean kill to get out
right off the bat especially with Trish
she's newer character Frieza so good
works from super noon but right now yeah
we're gonna get a hanky dama it's great
knock down on this is awesome
maybe make him get some smart elect AG
yeah he got this he got that key blast
out there again to from it second time
we've seen him get it he's gonna be a
snap great defense though from super
noon there yeah you just up back when he
saw that he was gonna have air -
pressure got out of there
hey backs off backs off you're just not
challenging that much he's just waiting
put them there with the lair yeah he
Larry's Yantra yeah
back spits out of there yeah punished on
the Colin and he couldn't make Christy
block to set up the kid buu assist Wow
what is that looking across on deck yeah
one three get the kill here much damage
as you can squeeze that of it two
characters left on each side sparking
both available yeah that was a that was
a pretty phat hitbox on that jump aah
that's crazy super noon using that GG
Goku beam going right into that dragon
rush make great use of how it locks you
down they're going right into that bar
I'm level three as well the beam is
really good because it hits upwards like
that diagonally then drags you back down
to the floor so you're just stuck in a
really bad spot sparks on a block son
doesn't want to deal with a mix-up there
and I can't blame them it's kind of a
rough spot to be counter Sparkle I don't
even know that was it kind of those
super late I'm surprised that he didn't
to H actually I mean he was committed to
the backlash but you know in this
version a lot of times it doesn't like
work the supernatural Louise man back -
we flip again by defending Aereo runs up
and super Dan just look at him like
chasing Chris now running at him whiff
and then dragon right that's one of the
best signs actually is like when you're
jumping over just completely whiffs and
has blocks then that you expect to be
there no just one yeah and this is an
important like character for super new
year you really don't want this to go
too - oh right like with the way he
plays of how fast he plays he needs to
overwhelm and smother and I think this
is an important kill frame to get here
try super - in there - denied Chris
playing nice and patient you see instant
air - back a lot he's trying to bait a
super - look for a 2h right right there
yeah that's what he's looking for the
air - back
pressure here goes the other side now I
like that power pole just to get out of
there missing the auto coma ban is okay
the counter vanish they're down techno
buttons from super noon they might have
actually hit I'm not sure it depends on
how early he did the supernational
we'll think fist yeah it is a lot of
waiting and you know only committing the
super - when they're in the air if you
can so that way you don't get to H for
free yeah you got to watch super dashing
in on GG Goku - if you guys got that
beam you're gonna buy it good break yeah
that was scary and that'd be him I think
super news going to it a lot and Chris
he's gonna jump super - to try to beat
it soon if he's not you know careful
with how he places it that's why you see
Christie jumping a little higher he's
hoping for him to commit to the be
mistaken super - this is huge a big jump
eight drop them down oh we missed it
yeah you got the delay that low to the
ground sting at the ground combo after I
probably been the kill are opposed to it
for Chris that's the Punisher - that
back right there is gonna be the kill
yeah I mean that's what I was talking
about when he's jumping a little higher
off the ground and the whole reason he
was doing that was because he was trying
to be super noon to commit to the beam
so they get a super - and punish it
really good recognition of Chris that
that's what exactly what super knew was
looking for Chris she is on fire here
looking like very convincing then you
might be on our grand finals yeah - Oh
looking great so far blocking the 6m Wow
oh my god he tried to take a dragon rush
completely miss that's unfortunate I
felt like Kevin in Rome alone like those
on my face that was yeah that was he got
robbed where's Aubrey Chris no he'll
take it he looked over at super ninjas
laugh like our well it'd be like
we vanished but admits he's gonna eat
the spirit ball
I think Spanish was a good try honestly
but sparks out early I think he's got to
get a hit on this sparking okay yeah
call low after and Sabrina's got all the
meter in the world to try to close this
out pretty one three kind of squeeze as
much as you can I mean the sparking
build you so much me to write that you
need to get kills from it and most of
the time those kills come from not only
the damage of it but the meter of bills
right you know you get five six meters
from a one party combo and you really
have to spend it why not be both yeah
that's perfect right that's best-case
scenario that that is great to H there
yeah as a long long time than he had to
see it and he's not gonna take the snap
his lowest yeah that's right because the
other characters that super Nunes lost
like character right so - I'll take the
damage on it instead of snapping a pig
across up but he's it a little too high
I think
I like the movement I'm seeing again
we're seeing that very patient movement
from both these players win those great
that's really unfortunate because super
noon had the button out already and
Christy I like guard canceling gumball
it's I think a good idea sometimes oh
wow it actually clipped by the way I
mean that was great yeah we're top super
well yeah it worked out like so weird
yeah it's like at this joint is super
two-asset box that ended up getting
being too far away for the jumping out
that is one character I think too that
has always been remained in strong on
super news team daddy's out of it yeah
she's a big one for Chris because he's
still sitting on sparking so you know
that character advantage is a big deal
especially when gumball gives you really
potent mix-ups so losing that assists
you know not having to do any more it's
a big win
yeah Auto combo drop the spirit bomb
honor a lot of damage this would be a
good opportunity cannot go but get that
Kuwait punished on free so that's gonna
be big damage yeah super new was trying
to beat us parking and Chris didn't go
for it but ended up catching the tag
anyway so this is gonna be great to
beaters for the kill I've won the one
throw the javelin wow we didn't even
need it at the powered up level one
damage that is so good a super super
good Oh Chris G has left here is this GT
go through can he pull it off he doesn't
sparking still left yes I just got to
find a good time to activate it to build
up three meters
drop the spear bomb on them this might
be what forces Christie to spark yeah I
think he's only really wants to spark if
super noon you know goes for like some
kind of pressure on boats gonna build
close to one meter that is the spark air
- cancel nice block oh I like that I
like the vanish using making use of that
sparking that's going on right now six
bars on decks for Chris G's spear bomb
absolutely
i Campos did a grip and thelo okay
Christine a great spot now right I mean
it was looking a little dire and he
doesn't have a lot of life but having
this parking available makes it so that
too touching with just this character is
gonna be a lot easier oh no Chris you
got greedy and it paid off
it's gonna be big should be the kill if
he doesn't drop its fear ball pretty
close
he's gonna do spear bomb dragon rush
yeah and then try to get the level one
after he going to Grand Finals
big comeback all the way from that
deficit and he just played super
composed that whole time I you know I
think the strategy a lot of time is for
super noon just get in there overwhelmed
Ryan Chris she is one of those players
that when his defenses on point it is so
tough to really find those clean hits
against them and anytime you do hit him
it feels like you have to work super
hard for it and then even the hit you
get it's like well I used all my assists
you know I spent sparking I use all the
stuff just to hit up man
I didn't even end up getting anything
too crazy about it as we see the bracket
here Cristiano move moving on that
winterside grand finals waiting for the
winner of our loser Sammy's and then
loser finals that the loser sent me is
gonna be next Nakia versus apology man
in case you guys haven't been paying
attention the winner of that will be
playing super noon we just saw lose to
Christian ji and this will be a fun one
I always like the interactions between
knock yell and apology man so those two
playing each others just like it should
be of its own yeah those two they
cracked with the way Derrick just
screams that apology man is like so
unnecessary but also hilarious he's
about to throw the chunk ladder yeah
it's gonna be it's gonna be something I
think for sure so I'm excited for that
match I believe we're gonna have a very
short break our last break and once we
come back from that we'll have top four
of the DB FZ action here so opal you
guys been enjoying everything at this
Tenkaichi event we'll catch you guys in
just a little bit